Freunde ich bin eigentlich gerade mitten
in den Weihnachtsvorbereitung aber ich
habe ein wichtiges Video für euch und
zwar habe ich ja dieses Knoblauchöl in
einem Video letztens gemacht das war
inspiriert von Brot mit Ei ich habe das
ganze erweitert und mein persönlichen
Touch dran zu geben und habe frischen
Knoblauch reingemacht jetzt habt ihr mir
in die Kommentare geschrieben dass man
bei frischem Knoblauch irgendwie Boot
toolismus irgendwie so eine relativ
seltene Krankheit bekommen kann was
wirklich sehr sehr selten passiert aber
wir wollen keinen Risiko eingehen
deshalb wenn ihr das gemacht habt macht
einfach folgendes ihr öffnet die Flasche
schüttet sie in einen Topf also das
Olivenöl eigentlich kann noch gar nichts
passiert sein in der kurzen Zeit in der
das jetzt gelagert wurde ich meine ich
habe das tiktok vor paar Tagen gemacht
erhitzt das einmal auf über 80 Grad
dadurch wird der Erreger abgetötet der
Knoblauch ist dann entsprechend auch
nicht mehr rot spült die Flasche aus und
füllt das am Ende wieder ein sehr
wichtig ihr wollt nichts verschenken was
potentiell in ein paar Monaten oder
Jahren vielleicht mal
gesundheitsschädlich ist deshalb sorry
dass ich da so uninformiert was
verbreitet habe ich werde in Zukunft auf
jeden Fall darauf achten dass das besser
recherchiert ist also bleibt gesund
genießt die Feiertage und sorry